foreign
[Music]
so let's get after it and have us
some good [ __ ] bread
um see slip and Jimmy you know the good
[ __ ] bread bit pessie I will argue is
better than Dave Landau
yeah I bet you've been saying that's
bread to your [ __ ] friends they don't
even get it that's that's a good
comedian
I'm saying something that has nothing to
do with Senator Cruz or his family it's
about the rest of us all those who are
expressing Sympathy for the cruise
family
I want you to think about how you are
ordinarily and what you you want to see
you want to see Chris Cuomo make the Ted
Cruz thing about himself
you're sympathetic or unsympathetic and
that includes me
now many of you have noticed I don't
swing at Ted Cruz or at any of the
players of the game the way I used to
some of you even question whether I
still have the fire oh it burns
kill switch engage song like what is he
doing
Chris is he gonna come out to CM Punk's
old me [ __ ] theme Chris what is wrong
with you buddy uh may I answer yeah yeah
he's very self-important uh very
narcissistic uh dumb Guido who thinks
his IQ is 40 points higher than it is
fair enough so he so he thinks he's like
he was 45. yeah exactly I mean that's
that sums them up that's why we love him
because he'll never stop giving us
content
I promise you that but not in the same
way and for multiple reasons
I think independent voters in the core
of this country are sick of that
even refereeing the game so he's going
from uh left wing Chris Cornell the
independent Chris Como I look at both
sides of the issues folks I sit there
and I analyze them now
my free agent shirt in my basement my
free agent shirt which is a very fancy
way of saying fire yes seriously I've
been a free agent a couple times too
buddy
as I tried to
I think you're sick of it I think you
want something better yeah you're done
with left and right you want reasonable
sure and I respect it and you're right
and but if you get in my face so talk
about my mother I'll [ __ ] you up God
help you
beautiful soul and a saint
designing my show for partisans who live
for that stuff but for you who want
better who wants more light and less
Heat
but I'm going to be honest with you
there's a personal reason as well
challenging year right understatement
Chris much
because of my [ __ ] sucking [ __ ]
brother
I wasn't even getting no [ __ ] no big
deal taught me a lot of things taught me
a lot of things some of them hard some
of them maybe I needed to learn
but you don't want to know something I
don't talk about as much
I don't know bro humility yeah you know
Grace quantum physics
any kind of math I do not talk about any
kind of math ever yeah yeah sure I don't
trust Greeks after that Pythagorean
theorem I'll tell you that right now
or something
it was harder on my family they paid a
price for no for what my brother did
that [ __ ]
don't talk about as much
the year was harder on my family they
paid a price for no good reason actually
for bad reason
Paparazzi keyboard Warriors
they were put in a bad position and
forced to answer for things that they
had nothing to do with
because of my decision to help my
brother and because too often with too
mean to too many people we do it for
sport because it works because
negativity is approximately I think it's
[ __ ] up the reason the reason they
fired him I still think is [ __ ] up we
even said it when it happened it's like
he's your brother man you're gonna help
your brother right like I don't care
what anybody says you know yeah to this
day I've said he literally got fired for
the most honorable act he ever exactly
like sticking up for his brother yeah I
mean what would you do you know see for
insight
and all's fair in Love and War right
now what kills me is I didn't see it
it's probably the steroid abuse
the only time will tell
s me
and as someone who grew up being bullied
and all the good stuff by your brother
if we're being fair you're being bullied
by your older brother yeah your older
Governor brother governor of your state
that comes along with who my dad and
[ __ ] it was the most ridiculous bullying
the world has ever seen as it was
you'd think I'd know better you'd think
I would have picked a different line of
work like what Chris what were you going
to be huh were you going to be a [ __ ]
rocket scientist huh where were you
gonna become
and there I was repeating the same
problem doing it to my own Chris would
be the a personal trainer at a gym in
any other [ __ ] timeline I guarantee
you it's Chris Cuomo's a personal
trainer that gets handsy with his
clients at other gyms in another
timeline
I hate it
so I don't do the job is the only person
that's ever taken the goat test from
Fallout and failed it okay because I
want to try to limit the rage that comes
to them for bad reason all right Fredo
calm down
and I know that's the right thing to do
you don't have to be an ass to be
critical
but it helps it doesn't hurt it doesn't
hurt
you don't have to try to destroy someone
to make a point or a shared perspective
but it's way more fun
I believe in disagreement with decency
you and Don Lemon sure [ __ ] didn't
seem very decent during covet and he
sure didn't seem very decent after after
they fired you and kept him
um
I think it's the key to a better future
for us and I want people in the game the
media the pundits players who are all
saying nice things right now
to remember that when they go back
the business as usual an ad to the
poison politics that dominates
because everybody right now is
acknowledging by their apparent
compassion that there is a cost to
destroying everyone and every it's so
funny how both Cuomo brothers were
completely pushed away by the left and
pushed and left to rot and now both of
them are trying to be independent almost
hey we're the independent almost now I
love Centrist I love that they're
[ __ ] the Centrist Cuomo Brothers
and for sport for Advantage because it
works
right now that's a good point but golf
on the chat if Kris Cuomo emerges from
quarantine and sees his shadow that's
two more years of lockdowns I bet you
they're all ready right now
social media
that's us Cuomo blames senator for what
happened with uh Cuomo says bro I looked
on Twitter and put in Como nobody is
talking about you I promise you you know
what they're talking about right now
Jake Shields think about Shake Shields
that's what they're talking about
nobody who I wish you would call a Nazi
he has [ __ ] seriously he's oh what a
great hold on this is a good Freeze
Frame there it is there it is hey oh hey
there you go taper they there you go hey
oh please Mom sorry Mom
he really does he looks like he just
dropped an F-bomb in front of his mother
yeah exactly
Mom sorry Mom sorry the guy from Casino
yeah I'll tell you what I'll go down
there I'll hit him in the head with a
[ __ ] bat Mom sorry no I get it I'm
sorry
exactly
oh what are the views on this video this
video has a uh
40K 40K
what do you mean I said hit him in his
freaking head I said freaking
after all kinds of BS Twisted to the
negative
and they know it's not fair they know
it's out of control don't ask me about
the tables
but they're doing it to score points
one crab I'm doing it for my clip
channel to be honest with you if we're
being honest we're doing it to have a
nice little clip on our Channel
it's the climb out what do the other
crabs do
pull him back what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] hold on
what crap remember when this is like
remember when Dee was doing noises why
did why do the crabs have flamethrowers
D this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right there
oh it's a landslide
points
one crab tries to climb out what are the
other people ahead Bill O'Reilly so they
are this is that this is it now this is
their thing now oh yeah every week they
do one call-in show I keep telling you
guys pull them back down
now
it's the wrong way to play the game
okay
is to try to be part of a solution
I learned a lesson
the best way to fight what you oppose is
to not be that thing
not just a cake you trust you tried I
dare you to stop trying to be a dumb
Guido right now [ __ ] do it as hard as
I'll give you all the money in our bank
account or or just an [ __ ] in general
can you stop doing that you're an
[ __ ] all that there's so much so much
like demonstrable evidence on videotape
of you being an [ __ ]
you make me so angry Susan that's the
face he's making now you'll make me so
[ __ ] angry Susan
you don't understand what he's saying
though guys it's simple if you don't
want to be something then you don't have
to be the thing that that thing is so
don't be it oh okay cool can we get
someone who's not [ __ ] or explain
this to me
attack what you oppose that's easy
can we be better
no I wish better for the Cruz family I
hope the senator is okay I hope his wife
is okay and I hope the kids are all
where they need him to be I really do
and I really hope that the rest of us
take a message in it because it doesn't
have to be directly related doesn't have
to have anything to do with it for it to
be a a moment worth
examining
if you care about them now care always
and in all ways if it doesn't have to do
with you you can still make it about
yourself folks Chris Cuomo outside
you're probably wondering how I made uh
how I made a senator's daughter trying
to kill herself about me I'll show you
my TED Talks
you know what he should be doing instead
of this like or at least for his podcast
he should just be he should if he's
gonna try to talk like this I would be
more apt to listen to him if he was
cooking yeah yes you know what I mean
like I'm trying to sauce with his finger
and stuff running around the kitchen
chopping up things like and I can watch
that's why I think
we really got to stop being more humble
and a white kitchen towel thrown over
his shoulder you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah sweetheart go get the onions
out of the fridge anyway like I was
saying [ __ ] I'd watch that well I would
watch that it would be so much better